c'est le fruit d'un travail réalisé tout
au long de l'année entre enseignants
enfants de l'école primaire
saint-exupéry est une artiste pour la
17e fois à magny les hameaux le livre
infinie a été remis par les enfants aux
anciens combattants à l'occasion de la
commémoration nationale du 8 mai de le
vivre à c'est complètement autre chose
on ressent vraiment toute l'émotion et
la passation justement du souvenir de la
mémoire avec aussi ce rassemblement
intergénérationnel je pense que pour eux
ça a été plus concret une transmission
symbole du devoir de mémoire
malgré les restrictions sanitaires en
vigueur il est essentiel d'avoir des
enfants qui portent les fleurs par
exemple tout à l'heure avec avec des
plus anciens qui nous passe un certain
nombre de messages à leur façon qui nous
donne en main propre le livre infinie et
qui étaient présents avec leurs parents
finalement même si la séance et pas
publics
ben voilà ils sont passés dans le
secteur et ils ont pu voir comment et la
cérémonie afin qu'un maximum de manille
quoi puissent avoir accès à l'hommage la
mairie a une nouvelle fois mise en place
un système de retransmission par visio
dès le début de la pandémie on a décidé
directement de faire des retransmissions
de cette cérémonie
retransmission de discours ou bien sinon
au fur et à mesure aussi des
possibilités du cadre sanitaire
la retransmission de la cérémonie
complète c'est ce qu'on est en train de
faire depuis les deux dernières
cérémonies 19 mars et 8 mai aujourd'hui
une situation sanitaire qui n'aura pas
empêché certains citoyens de se tenir à
distance
écoutez les noms et se souvenir des
morts pour la france de magny les
hameaux